>> Greg: PREVIOUSLY ON
"GUTFELD!."
THE MOST IMPORTANT QUESTION I
HAVE TO ASK YOU IS HOW ABOUT MY
RATINGS?
>> Mr. Trump: YOUR RATINGS ARE
FABULOUS.
YOU ARE THE KING OF LATE NIGHT.
YOU ARE GETTING SOME VERY
UNTALENTED PEOPLE.
I'M NOT SO SURE HOW GREAT THAT
IS.
THEY ARE SO BAD, AND IT'S ABOUT
TIME SOMEBODY CAME IN AND YOU'RE
REALLY BEATING THEM BADLY, GREG.
>> Greg: I FEEL LIKE I'M
BEATING UP ON PEOPLE.
>> Mr. Trump: THEY ARE NOT
VERY TALENTED, YOU ARE.
>> Greg: I AM MILDLY TALENTED.
>> Mr. Trump: YOU ARE VERY
DIFFERENT.
>> Greg: YES, I AM.
THAT'S TRUE.
CLAP AWAY.
IF THAT IS NOT EMMY AWARD
WINNING STUFF, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
IS.
MAYBE IF I SENT CONTAGIOUS
PEOPLE TO NURSING HOMES AND THEN
GRABBED MY COWORKERS ASSES, I
WOULD HAVE A CHANCE.
BUT I WON'T.
BUT THE FUN HASN'T STOPPED YET
BECAUSE IT IS TIME FOR...
>> ANOTHER MEETING OF THE MINDS
PART THREE.
>> Greg: PART THREE OF THE
GREATEST PRESIDENTIAL INTERVIEW
IN THE HISTORY OF PRESIDENTIAL
INTERVIEWS.
THAT'S NOT FUNNY.
WARNING, THIS INTERVIEW IS SO
POWERFUL IT MAY CHANGE FOREVER
THE WAY YOU LOOK AT THE WORLD
AND ESPECIALLY NEED.
BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT.
GREG'S SEVEN JOKES.
I ENVISION GREG BRADY PLAYING
THE ORGAN.
UPSTAIRS, IN THE ATTIC.
THIS AFTERNOON PRESIDENT BIDEN
UNVEILED HIS SIX PRONGED PLAN TO
FIGHT COVID.
HE WAS ORIGINALLY CALLED A SIX
STEP PLAN.
JOE IS NOT GOOD WITH STEPS.
BIDEN ALSO PRIORITIZE GETTING
KIDS BACK INTO SCHOOL WHERE THEY
ARE EASIER TO SNIFF.
JOE BIDEN IS ALSO PREPARING TO
SUE TEXAS OVER THE NEW
ANTIABORTION LAWS.
THAT'S RIGHT BEFORE HEADING TO
MASS TO RECEIVE COMMUNION.
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE CATHOLIC.
THEY ARE PRO-LIFE.
HE WANTS UNBORN CHILDREN TO DIE.
YOU SEE THE CONNECTION.
MEANWHILE, THE TALIBAN IS
EXPECTED TO CONTINUE THEIR BAN
ON MUSIC WHICH MEANS AFGHANS CAN
ONLY LISTEN TO MAROON 5.
>> Tyrus: TURNED THE LAUGH
TRACK ON.
>> Greg: IN OTHER NEWS,
CONGRESSMAN ADAM SCHIFF URGED
FACEBOOK TO ADDRESS THE SPREAD
OF COVID-19 VACCINE
MISINFORMATION ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
THE COMPANY SPRUNG INTO ACTION
INSTANTLY DELETING THE ACCOUNT
OF ANTHONY FAUCI.
YESTERDAY A PROTESTER THROUGH AN
EGG AT GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE
LARRY ELDER.
THE EGGING CONFIRMED TWO THINGS
WE ALREADY KNEW ABOUT LIBERALS.
ONE, THEY HATE BLACK
REPUBLICANS.
AND TWO, THEY THROW LIKE A GIRL.
THE DEADLY EGG WAS NEVER
RECOVERED BUT DETECTIVES DID
FIND SEVERAL SHELL FRAGMENTS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LAUGH.
THAT'S YOUR SEVEN JOKES.
I'M NOW TIME FOR PURGATORY WITH
OUR 45TH PRESIDENT,
DONALD TRUMP.
TAKE IT AWAY.
I'VE GOT TO ASK ABOUT HUNTER
BIDEN'S NEW PROFESSION.
HAVE YOU SEEN ANY OF HIS
PAINTINGS?
>> Mr. Trump: I HAVEN'T SEEN
THEM.
I'VE SEEN SOME NEWSPAPER SHOTS.
>> Greg: COULD YOU IMAGINE
THAT WAS --
>> Mr. Trump: DON JR. HAS
DECIDED TO GO INTO PAINTING.
HE HAS NEVER PAINTED BEFORE.
HE WANTS 500,000 A SHOT AND YOU
KNOW WHAT THEY DON'T EVEN GO
AFTER HIM.
>> Greg: HE PAINTS WITH A
STRAW WHICH IS A NEW USE FOR A
STRAW FOR HIM.
>> Mr. Trump: WHEN I HEARD
THIS ONE, THIS ONE, EVEN THE
FAKE NEWS MEDIA WILL NOT ALLOW.
HE IS SELLING HIS PAINTINGS.
IF MY KIDS EVER DID THAT, THEY
COULD DO GOOD THINGS.
I HAVE A SON, RAISED $20 MILLION
FOR ST. JUDE'S.
HE WAS UNDER TWO YEARS OF
INVESTIGATION AND GOT NOTHING
OUT OF IT.
NOTHING.
TWO YEARS OF INVESTIGATION.
HE RAISED 20 MILLION GOT THE
MOST BEAUTIFUL LETTER FROM THE
HEAD OF ST. JUDE'S THAT THIS
YOUNG MAN, I WON'T EVEN SAY
WHICH ONE OF MY KIDS.
>> Greg: IT WOULD BE DON JR.
OR ERIC STARTED SELLING SKETCHES
AND GIVING THE MONEY TO DRUG
ADDICTION PROGRAMS.
SOME REALLY PRIMITIVE SKETCHES
BEFORE HUNTER EVER SELLS A
PAINTING.
>> Mr. Trump: IF YOU GO,
DURING THE PRESIDENCY TO DO
THIS.
I THINK THE PAINTINGS OF THE
LEAST OF IT.
YOU KNOW THAT.
THAT'S THE LEAST OF IT.
>> Greg: THE GUN VIOLATIONS.
>> Mr. Trump: WE HAD A MUCH
SOFTER JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
LET'S SAY THEY DIDN'T LIKE DOING
THAT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT I DON'T
WANT TO SEE A FAMILY IN TROUBLE.
HE HAS GOT SOME DIFFICULTIES
WHICH ARE VERY SERIOUS
DIFFICULTIES IN TERMS OF WHAT
HAPPENED TO HIM WITH THE VIEWS,
CETERA, ET CETERA.
I TELL YOU WHAT, YOU CAN'T DO IT
REPUBLICANS.
SOME OF THE REPUBLICANS,
ESPECIALLY THE RHINOS.
WE HAVE SOME VERY STUPID
REPUBLICANS.
DON'T YOU SOMETIMES HAVE TO
FIGHT FIRE WITH FIRE.
>> Greg: WHAT ARE YOUR PLANS
FOR 2024?
>> Mr. Trump: I LOVE OUR
COUNTRY.
TWO OR THREE YEARS AGO YOU MIGHT
NOT OF BEEN THAT HAPPY.
BUT ANOTHER GOING BE VERY HAPPY.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
I'LL MAKE A DECISION IN THE
NOT-TOO-DISTANT FUTURE.
I LOVE OUR COUNTRY AND I THINK A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
VERY HAPPY.
YOU LOOK AT THE POLL NUMBERS, I
CERTAINLY LIKE THAT.
WE GOT ON THE OTHER DAY, 98%
APPROVAL IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
REAGAN HAD 87.
WE HAVE A 90% APPROVAL RATING.
THAT MAKES ME FEEL GOOD.
IT MAKES ME FEEL APPRECIATED.
NOT LIKE A GUY LIKE YOU THEY CAN
BE CRITICAL.
IN THE PAST.
ONLY THE PAST.
>> Greg: I HAVE TO ASK, DO YOU
MISS TWITTER?
DO YOU TWEET IN YOUR HEAD?
>> Mr. Trump: A LOT OF PEOPLE
THINK TWITTER WAS BAD FOR ME.
I DISAGREE.
I THINK IT WAS GOOD FOR ME.
TWITTER HAS BECOME A VERY BORING
PLACE.
WHEN I WENT ONTO TWITTER 12
YEARS AGO, TWITTER WAS A FAILED
OPERATION.
IT BECAME SUCCESSFUL AND A LOT
OF PEOPLE SAID I HAD A LOT TO DO
WITH IT.
WHEN THEY TOOK ME OFF, I HAD WAY
OVER 100 MILLION PEOPLE.
THEN IF YOU ADD FACEBOOK AND
EVERYTHING ELSE, IT'S OVER
200 MILLION PEOPLE.
THAT'S A LOT.
YOU GO FROM 200 MILLION PEOPLE
TO NOTHING OVERNIGHT.
WHAT I DO KNOW IS I HAVE SAVE
AMERICA AND I RELEASE THINGS
THAT I'M TREMENDOUS PLAY.
WE ARE SUING TWITTER, FACEBOOK,
GOOGLE, CLASS ACTION SUIT.
ANYONE WANTS TO JOIN, PLEASE
JOIN.
I THINK IT'S A GREAT LAWSUIT.
THESE PEOPLE ARE SICK.
ZUCKERBERG USED TO COME, THE
LOCKBOXES.
THE LOCKBOXES ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
HE USED TO COME TO THE
WHITE HOUSE TO KISS MY ASS.
I HAVE THE HEAD OF FACEBOOK
COMING WITH HIS LOVELY WIFE AND
THEY COME HAVE DINNER WITH ME AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU SEE WHAT THEY DO ABOUT ME
AND ABOUT REPUBLICANS AND THAT
SORT OF CRAZY.
THAT'S THE WAY THE WORLD WORKS.
>> Greg: WATCHING HOW THE
MEDIA TREATS JOE BIDEN, IT'S AN
OBVIOUS QUESTION BUT WORTH
BRINGING UP.
THERE'S ALWAYS A GAME THAT WE
PLAY ON "THE FIVE."
IMAGINE IF ITS TRUMP.
JOE BIDEN LEAVING BEHIND AFGHAN
TRANSLATORS.
IF IT WERE YOU, YOU WOULD BE
CALLED A RACIST, CORRECT?
>> Mr. Trump: THEY WOULD BE
IMPEACHING ME.
>> Greg: NOW YOU HAVE THIS
PHONE CALL, THIS PHONE CALL THAT
HE MADE TO THE AFGHAN PRESIDENT
ASKING THEM TO LIVE.
THAT IS NOT A PERFECT PHONE
CALL.
>> Mr. Trump: MY CALL WAS A
PERFECT CALL.
>> Greg: HOW DO THEY SQUARE
THAT IN THEIR HEADS, KNOWING
WHAT THEY DID BEFORE.
TALKING ABOUT THE MEDIA.
>> Mr. Trump: MY CALL.
WE SENT IT TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHO THEY WERE.
CERTAIN DIVISIONS.
THEY CALLED BACK AND THEY SAID
WE READ THIS TRANSCRIPT THREE OR
FOUR TIMES.
WHAT EXACTLY ARE YOU LOOKING
FOR?
THESE ARE GUYS THAT ARE LOOKING
AT DRUG DEALS IN ALL SORTS OF
BAD STUFF.
THEY GO, WHAT IS THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR?
THEY COULDN'T FIGURE IT OUT.
IT WAS A PERFECT CALL.
WHEN YOU WATCH THIS CALL, THIS
WAS NOT A GOOD CALL.
THIS WAS NOT A GOOD CALL.
>> Greg: HE WAS ASKING HIM TO
LIE IN ORDER TO MAKE HIM LOOK
BAD, MAY BE TO MAKE HIMSELF LOOK
BETTER OR POLITICALLY, WHATEVER.
>> Mr. Trump: HE'S BEEN A COOK
FOR A LONG TIME.
HE COULDN'T GET IT ALL INTO THE
HELICOPTER.
DO YOU THINK SOME PEOPLE AT THE
AIRPORT --
>> Greg: IT KILLS ME.
THAT'S OUR MONEY.
>> Mr. Trump: YOU DON'T HEAR
THAT STORY.
YOU DON'T HEAR THAT MUCH ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN ANYMORE.
I WATCH THE EVENING NEWS AND
THEY TALK ABOUT EVERYTHING THEY
CAN BUT THEY DON'T LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT AFGHANISTAN.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, THAT THAT
WAS POWERFUL.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO
NOW.
WE'VE GOT TO TURN TO AN
IMMEDIATE POST-INTERVIEW WITH
THE INTERVIEWER.
>> JEAN NELSON REPORTS WITH JEAN
NELSON.
>> LET ME SAY I THOUGHT LAST
NIGHT'S INTERVIEWER WAS THE BEST
I'VE EVER SEEN UNTIL TONIGHT'S
INTERVIEW.
HANDS-DOWN THE BEST THING I'VE
EVER WITNESSED.
>> Greg: I HAVE TO AGREE WITH
YOU AND I DID THE INTERVIEW.
YOU'D BE SURPRISED TO LEARN MORE
THERE WILL BE A PART FOUR LEADER
OF THE SHOW AND TOMORROW A PART
FIVE.
>> WOW.
I CAN'T WAIT.
GENE, YOU WERE ON MY SHOW
YESTERDAY.
GENE NELSON REPORTS.
>> Greg: DO YOU WORK OUT?
HOW MUCH DO YOU BENCH?
>> ABOUT 250.
DO YOU LIFT WEIGHTS?
>> Greg: I WORK OUT BUT I
DON'T USE WEIGHTS.
I USE THE BODY WEIGHT OF MY
WORKOUT PARTNER.
I HAVE HIM STRADDLE ME ON MY
BACK AND THAT I DO SQUAT
THRUSTS.
SHE WANT TO GO WORK OUT?
>> I DON'T HAVE MY WORKOUT
CLOSE.
>> Greg: YOU WON'T NEED ANY.
>> HERE HE IS.
>> Greg: LET'S WELCOME
TONIGHT'S GUESTS!
THIS FORMER PLACEKICKER IS UP,
AND HE'S GOOD!
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
AND FORMER GOP CONGRESSMAN
JASON CHAFFETZ.
THIS EX-PUBLIC DEFENDER
HAS TAKEN MORE PRISON CALLS
THAN KAT.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL AIDE
KASH PATEL.
SHE LIKES HER MEN TALL,
DARK, AND ON LIFE SUPPORT.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
AND EVEN HIS INNER CHILD IS
BIGGER THAN MOST PEOPLE.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK AND THE
NWA WORLD TELEVISION CHAMPION,
TYRUS.
TONIGHT WE SAW JOE BIDEN
TALKING, DID A PRESSER.
TYRESE, YOU MADE A VERY GOOD
POINT.
WHEN YOU COMPARE JOE BIDEN TO
TRUMP IN THE WORLD OF VACCINES
AND HE SAW THE INTERVIEW LAST
NIGHT TALKING ABOUT PERSUADING
MY WIFE TO GET THE VACCINE,
THERE IS A NOTICEABLE CONTRAST
BETWEEN WHO CAN PERSUADE AND WHO
CAN'T.
>> Tyrus: HE WASN'T EVEN THAT.
HE TALKED TO SOMEONE WHO WAS A
PARENT, A FATHER, LEADER AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT WAS ME PUT SOME
FACTS BEHIND IT.
HE WAS A VERY UN-TRUMPLIKE
RESPONSE.
WE ARE USED TO THE NARRATIVE OR
HE DOESN'T CARE AND HE SELFISH
BUT HE WAS GIVING YOU GOOD
REASONS AND HE WAS RESPECTING
YOUR WIFE'S DECISION NOT TO DO
IT.
FROM THE OTHER SIDE OF IT, THE
SIDE THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE THAT
WAY, HE WAS BASICALLY
THREATENING US BY TELLING
SOMEBODY WE ARE LOSING OUR
PATIENTS WITH YOU.
THAT'S HIS FRUSTRATION.
YOU HIRED YOUR ADMINISTRATION.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING RID OF
ANYONE.
THE WORST PART, THE REASON WHY
THAT DIDN'T GET A LOT OF
ATTENTION WAS BECAUSE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA IS WHOLE NARRATIVE IS IT'S
THE NUMBERS THAT DON'T GET
VACCINATED AND THOSE ARE THE
ONES HURTING THE COUNTRY.
THE LEADER OF THE TRUMPERS IS
NOT ONLY VACCINATED, HE'S
PROMOTING TO GET VACCINATED AND
DOING IT IN A WAY WHERE YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH IT.
HE DIDN'T INSULT YOUR WIFE.
HE DIDN'T SAY IF I WAS YOU, I
WOULD DIVORCE HER.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT -- WE ARE
SEEING THE SIZE OF WHAT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE COME UP WITH
THOSE TWO INTERVIEWS TOGETHER,
RUN THEM SIDE-BY-SIDE.
WHO IS THE BULLY?
WHO ARE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
GOING TO LISTEN TO?
IT'S PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Greg: JASON, WHEN I SAW
BIDEN TODAY, AND I'M GOING LIKE,
HE'S GOING TO REELECT TRUMP AND
TRUMP WINDS IF HE DECIDES TO
RUN.
>> Jason: YOU'RE EXACTLY
RIGHT.
HE WAS ANGRY, UPSET, TRYING TO
BLAME EVERYBODY ELSE.
THEN GIVES THE EXCEPTION TO
POSTAL WORKERS.
EVERYBODY IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS TO DO IT EXCEPT
THE POSTAL WORKERS.
IF YOU REALLY THINK ABOUT IT,
WHO ARE THE PEOPLE WITHIN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT YOU
INTERACT WITH MOST?
IT'S THE POSTAL WORKERS.
THEY COME TO YOUR HOUSE EVERY
DAY FOR GOODNESS' SAKES.
YOU GO TO THE COUNTER TO BUY
STAMPS AND MAIL THINGS.
BUT THEY GET A PASS.
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
DONALD TRUMP, I THINK HE CREATED
THE VACCINE, AND IT WAS
KAMALA HARRIS AND JOE BIDEN THAT
WERE SAYING OH, I WOULDN'T DO IT
IF HE WAS INVOLVED.
>> Greg: USING HIS CRITERIA,
BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS WERE A
THREAT TO OUR PUBLIC SAFETY.
THEY WERE A THREAT TO OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY BY SAYING DON'T USE THE
VACCINE.
BECAUSE BIDEN MADE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT THE 80 MILLION PEOPLE WHO
AREN'T VACCINATED ARE A THREAT
TO PUBLIC SAFETY.
HE SAID THAT.
KASH, YOU WORKED IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
DO YOU THINK IS GOING TO WORK
AGAIN -- RUN AGAIN?
>> Kash: 100%.
>> Greg: HOW DO YOU THINK IT'S
GOING TO GO?
THIS IS GOING TO BE THE CRAZIEST
THING EVER.
>> Kash: I WAS TALKING TO
TYRUS ABOUT IT.
DOES BIDEN STAY FOR A FULL YEAR.
DOES KAMALA TRY TO COME IN.
IT'S A POLITICAL DISASTER.
THEY HAVE VIOLATED, EVERY LAW
THEY PUT AGAINST ROME, THEY ARE
VIOLATING.
COVID, AFGHANISTAN, THE BORDER.
I DON'T KNOW THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP NEEDS TO DO
ANYTHING IF HE DOES DECIDE TO
RUN AGAIN IN 2024.
HE JUST NEEDS TO LET THEM KEEP
RUINING THE COUNTRY
UNFORTUNATELY.
THEY WILL ELECT HIM AND PUT HIM
BACK IN OFFICE.
>> Greg: KAT, LAST NIGHT AFTER
THE INTERVIEW, THERE WAS A
LEFT-WING BLOG SAYING WE ADDED A
LAUGH TRACK TO THE INTERVIEW AND
IT WAS THE AUDIENCE THAT WAS
LAUGHING.
THEY HAVE NOT TAKEN IT DOWN.
MSN.COM RAN IT.
PEOPLE ARE RUNNING IT.
SHOULDN'T THEY TAKE THAT DOWN
NOW THAT THEY KNOW THEY WERE
WRONG?
>> Kat: THEY SHOULD BUT ISN'T
IT KIND OF THE GREATEST
COMPLIMENT EVER?
WE ARE SO FUNNY THAT PEOPLE
THINK WE CAN'T POSSIBLY BE THAT
FUNNY.
BUT WE ARE.
AND I THINK IT ALSO SHOWS JUST
HOW IN A BUBBLE THEY ARE THAT
THEY THOUGHT THERE IS NO --
REMEMBER WHEN THE CHAUFFEUR
STARTED, THEY WERE STARTING
RUMORS THAT IT WAS CANCELED
AFTER THREE DAYS.
NOW WE ARE BEATING EVERYBODY
ELSE.
THEY WILL NEVER LEARN THAT IF
THEY DON'T GET OUTSIDE THEIR
BUBBLE, THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE ANY ACCESS TO EVERYONE ELSE
OUT THERE WHICH IS MORE THAN
FIVE PEOPLE.
>> Greg: HAVE GOT TO ASK, WHAT
WERE YOUR FEELINGS MARCHING
BIDEN AS A LIBERTARIAN TODAY?
>> Kat: I'M OBVIOUSLY PISSED
OFF.
WHO DOES HE THINK HE IS?
IF YOU DON'T OWN YOUR BODY, YOU
DON'T LIVE IN A FREE SOCIETY.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
YOU CAN APPLY THIS LOGIC TO ANY
OTHE